hello there and welcome to Cowboy hour
with Alex Yeehaw I asked my patrons
which precon they wanted me to look at
from Outlaws at Thunder Junction and a
plurality wanted to see Grand Larsen so
in this video I'm going to look at that
precon and I'm going to ask three
questions what is the deck trying to do
how well is it doing that and how could
it be improved to better accomplish that
task with that framework set up let's
talk about the commander here we have
ganty Kenny Inquisitor ganty reduces the
cost of your stolen spells and and
thieves the top guard of an opponent's
Library whenever you get through combat
damage on them my first thought when I
saw this is that this card is almost
identical to another Commander set card
that saw reprint last year in both
effect and power level Ramirez Depetro
Pillager they both Exile opposing cards
to play Whenever opponents are hit they
both go away to pay for part of the cost
of the stolen cards and for an extra
mana and an extra color ganty has the
benefits of not being restricted to
Pirates being able to play opposing
lands and being able to spend Mana of
any type on Stolen spells luckily I
actually quite enjoy this design I find
the design of stealing cards as a result
of hitting multiple opponents to be fun
and encouraging of dynamic gameplay
theft as a general archetype is fun in
that it scales to table power level but
where some theft decks go wrong is in
making theft the whole game plan and
having absolutely no plan for winning
outside of Ying opposing bombs this will
be okay against opposing mid-range decks
some of the time but it will struggle if
you get unlucky or if you're facing in
off against Decks that are more
synergistic which win through cards
working well together rather than
powerful individual cards I like the
design of ganty and Ramirez because
conditioning a deck's theft on it
dealing combat damage to one or more
players is kind of like bumpers on the
sides of a bowling alley it prevents
deck builders from making the classic
blunder of forgetting a win plan since
the cards needed to do the theft
creatures that aren't being blocked are
also a thing that will win games with
that out of the way let's talk about
ganty in particular I classify ganty as
a softt payoff a payoff that is pretty
easy to get some value off of but which
scales only modestly with additional
inputs the amount of cards stolen per
turn by ganty caps it three and a one
Mana discount on Stolen spells is also
pretty modest for a five Mana Commander
meaning that we'll likely be falling
behind if we aren't maxing out the
advantage we can from ganty starting
reasonably early in the game for this
reason I expect some amount of a ganty
deck to be made up of evasive creatures
that can get down to thieving not long
after ganty has hit the board it doesn't
need to be a whole ton one trigger for
each opponent means we're not playing
edri or anything but if we're not
getting three triggers per turn a decent
amount of the time we're leaving
advantage on the table another possible
Choice with ganty would be running
additional cards that steal but running
too many of these effects might be a bit
of a trap we only have so much Mana to
spend on opposing cards so these are
going to be the immediate two things I
look at a decent amount of evasive
creatures for getting ganty triggers and
maybe a modest amount of other cards
that steal looking at the creature base
of the deck we do see 18 creatures with
flying or another form of hard evasion
there are also a number of cards that
encourage dealing combat damage to a
player a category which obviously
includes the commander as well as a
result this deck has a decently potent
evasive Creatures game plan which it can
use to generate value off the commander
and other cards as expected we can also
see a small Suite of cards in the 99
that can steal cards and reduce the cost
of stolen cards and these will naturally
lead the deck into a late game plan of
playing lots of opposing cards using
theft in tandem with its evasive
creatures to bring the deck to Victory
so that seems to be the plan but how is
the deck doing with this game plan I'll
start with what I like here one of my
biggest criticisms of the blame game
precon was that the Mana base was quite
bad Wizards please just put things to
tap for colored Mana in your precons
just do it I know you can thank you so
did my pleading to Wizards of the Coast
lead to any Improvement well this Mana
base is honestly pretty good the
colorless utility lands are capped at
two and the deck runs sets of temples
pain lands check lands and bad filters
as well as a spattering of other du
including two good filtering lands
Wizards of the Coast seems to have made
the choice to give this preon a $30 Mana
base rather than give one or two
powerful cards to justify the precon
price and I honestly fully support this
new players need good lands a lot more
than they need a trouble in pairs now
that said there are places to improve
with this Mana base I'm going to be
talking about one Improvement a bit
later in this video and I have a whole
video on building a Mana base that's in
the pipeline but the overall message I'm
trying to get across here is that this
Mana base is pretty good and you can
pick up and play with this deck without
worrying too much about getting color
screwed or Mana screwed another thing I
like is that this deck has a decent
amount of removal the deck has two
creatures that Bonk stuff when they hit
players a couple board wipes and a
handful of pieces of targeted removal
it's also running a couple counter
spells though both are playing into the
theft Vibe here and end up being a bit
subpar as a result for reasons I'll talk
about a bit later in addition to this
the deck's ramp suite and value engines
are decent enough which should allow the
deck to keep on chugging into the late
game and not run out of steam the deck's
ramp draw and interaction will also be
supplemented by cards stolen from
opponents though I support the choice to
have a decent amount in to start with in
these categories so that we're not
relying too much on opponents in order
to play the game okay so that's the
stuff I like with that out of the way
what do I dislike about this precon so
this deck reminds me a lot of older
precons in terms of the cohesiveness of
its Vision or lack thereof there are two
different game plans here evasive
creature Beatdown and theft and actually
my first impression when looking at this
deck is that they might play decently
well together the commander is clearly
trying to act as a point of fusion here
and there are a number of creatures that
play well into both the evasive creature
plan and the theft plan so what's the
problem well there are a few issues at
Play here one is that the deck isn't
running enough evasive creatures and the
ones it does have cost too much mana on
average I'd say the deck almost always
wants to have one or more evasive
creatures in play by the time it gets
its Commander out but the list only
contains 12 evasive creatures below five
Mana which isn't a very reliable count
for getting such a pivotal type of card
the deck could be looking to develop
some 5 to seven Mana beaters and play
the commander a bit later but this
requires more ramp than the deck is
currently running and also doesn't
utilize the commander as well overall
the current Suite of evasive creatures
just doesn't work for me this deck wants
three ganty triggers a turn and that's
just not going to be consistently
fulfilled by this selection another
issue is that there are lots of cards
that do some sort of stealing oriented
thing but don't require paying Mana to
cast the cards this might seem normal at
first blush but there's actually
basically no mechanical connection
between these cards and the theft theme
as a whole they're identical to a random
mid-range beater as far as cohesion and
Synergy are concerned this is not to say
that these cards are all bad or not
worth running thieving skydiver is a
lovely card dazzling Sphinx is a solid
evasive creature and the ninjas are fun
payoff for evasive creatures what it is
to say though is that this deck is
effectively spending some number of card
slots on Flavor which isn't an
objectively wrong choice but for a mass
Market playable out of the box product
it's certainly a choice I ran 30 play
tests with the deck and overall it had
some good curve outs usually either
Landing quality two and three drops into
the commander or ramping into one of the
deck's bigger threats but it also had a
lot of not great curve outs in 15 of the
30 Games the deck failed to curve out in
a way that would allow it to
meaningfully launch into a game plan by
Turn 5 to six this failure can manifest
a number of different ways but the most
common ones were failing to spend its
mana on turns 2 to four playing out
cards that weren't impactful having
disjointed card types and failing to
gain enough Mana to accomplish the tasks
that the deck's draws might allow for
the deck did occasionally Miss land
drops and have awkward color situations
though this definitely wasn't one of the
more pressing issues and it's also
likely fixable with a bit more early
filtering overall I can definitely see
this deck feeling pretty great with
certain sets of draws but a lot of
rollouts with this deck are kind of
disjointed and awkward so what could
this deck do to improve first of all I
want to talk about some cards I just
generally dislike cunning rhetoric is a
mixture of a defense card and a theft
card but it doesn't actually accomplish
either task your opponents can choose
not to send small scale attacks your way
to prevent you from getting value but
when they do want to attack you the
downside of getting a single card exiled
for up to a full Board of creatures
attacking is just not a deterring factor
in the slightest next up void attendant
I get the vision and I love the idea of
repurposing a forgotten uncommon from
2015 but the card just isn't that useful
here this deck can't do much with tokens
it has enough draw to not need a Mana
sync and doesn't have enough instant
speed plays to make it useful as a Mana
banking option another card I dislike is
mimeoplasm this deck has no Mill of any
kind and One Singular card that causes
you to discard making our boy plasm a
pretty dead draw before the late game
yet another card I hate here is stolen
goods the average non-land card in an
EDH deck is like 3.5 Mana so you're
getting less value than the amount of
Mana you paid and what you get will
likely be unrelated to what you're
trying to do at any given moment next up
redundant cards I strongly dislike
predator's hour it does the same thing
as the command Zone but without any real
upside other than a possible tokens plan
I like dream thief's bandana a bit
better but it still Compares very
unfavorably to a similar equipment such
as mask of memory or mask of riddles
running either of these cards when the
deck doesn't even have enough evasive
creatures to consistently get its
triggers each turn feels wrong on a
pretty fundamental level it's at this
point I should jump back to the two
counter spells I mentioned earlier both
cost a lot of mana and high cost counter
spells with added bonuses do work but
mostly only in drao style control decks
this is because these decks will often
run spells that further their game plan
at instant speed most often card draw
and this allows them to counter a thing
if they need to but still have a way to
spend that mana on the endstep before
their turn if they don't end up
countering it anything by contrast this
deck runs very little at instant speed
meaning that if it holds up four or five
Mana for a counter spell that's just
wasted Mana if the counter spell doesn't
get used and this will often incentivize
players to counter something largely
Irrelevant in order to not waste the
Mana plasm capture is also very symol
dense so I'd cut it for a lower cost
counter spell like negate smirking spell
Jacker will stay in for now despite my
misgivings about its Mana cost and this
is because it's also a 33 creature with
flying which means that countering
something largely irrelevant is still a
mostly acceptable outcome with those
initial cuts out of the way I think
there are two possible paths forward for
this deck and those two paths are play
more into the big theft stuff by adding
more ramp or play more into the combat
damage element by adding evasive
creatures and evasion basically take the
two things the deck is doing and make it
focus more on one of those I'm choosing
the second one and that's for two
reasons firstly I don't think G should
be thought of as a pure theft Commander
the requirement of hitting opponents is
already pushing the deck in a somewhat
aggressive Direction and spending too
much Deck space on other theft cards and
theft payoffs worsens the deck's ability
to get in for combat damage and get
ganty triggers the other reason is that
this deck's alternative Commander Felix
5 boots is a fun card that is clearly
pushing for a more combat damage
oriented version of things so I chose to
take qes from that as well I justify
this here because I personally would
choose to cut quite a lot of cards that
fit into the theft theme and I could see
that being a contentious Choice doc
orlock just reducing the cost of stolen
cards isn't good enough Oblivion s
doesn't do enough villainous wealth this
deck isn't really a ramp deck and
playing villainous wealth with a Mana
spend of less than 10 won't be worth it
most of the time chaos wand also funny
and also not good enough outside of a
big Mana deck extract brain is similarly
awkward outside of a ramp deck because
the ideal hit is a big boss
but you'll be battling against time to
play it with a big enough X before your
opponent is able to play the
hypothetical threat and you also might
end up targeting a player only to find
nothing impactful in their hand what am
I bringing in for these cards the most
notable type of card I'm adding is what
I'll call evasive utility beaters
creatures that are lowc cost and have
both some sort of evasion and some sort
of benefit that Smooths out the deck's
game plan the first three of these I'm
adding are Malcolm aluring scoundrel
lutter IL cor and susp ious stowaway the
package here is great two Mana evasive
creatures that also offer looting on hit
and these will help smooth out draws and
filter away unneeded cards siren storm
Tamer is another solid ad offering a bit
of protection in addition to being an
evasive creature thousand faced Shadow
is another utility one drop and this has
the benefit of allowing us to slip
through something like a silent blade
Oni on a crowded board since the token
is unblockable due to being created
after the declare blockers phase I'm
also adding a couple three to four cost
utility beers with one of these being
drana Liberator of malare this card is
going to help with the Beatdown game
plan and the fact that it Buffs
everything else before combat damage is
a nice touch Frankle master of pranks is
another utility beater that can offer a
wide range of use cases depending on
what the deck needs or what would set
back opponents my final utility beater
ad is Kellen inquisitive Prodigy a card
that also adds a bit of ramp to the deck
I don't think this deck needs a lot of
ramp but I think a gentle increase to
the amount of ramp isn't a bad idea
either another addition I opted for is
Wayward sword tooth a solid beater that
allows for extra land plays I like the
extra land plays in Theft decks because
they allow the deck to ramp using
opposing lands I also added mask of
riddles and swapped out dark Steel Ingot
for Sonic Screwdriver to increase the
amount of evasion in the deck as being
able to swing something like a fallen
Shinobi or a silent plate Oni through a
crowded board is quite nice from there
my other non-land additions were a
couple counter spells and a removal
spell just to give this deck a bit more
ability to deal with concerning things
opponents are doing the deck wasn't
doing terrible on this but it has the
deck space for a bit more interaction
due to the value it has in the command
zone so I'm going to give it that
interaction now onto the Mana base as I
said this deck's Mana base is pretty
good with the biggest issue I note being
that its checklands don't have as much
support as I'd prefer as a quick fix to
this I choose to swap out the temples
for dominar United typed lands ideally
an incremental change for the deck would
be to swap these out for carav Manor
duels but those are going for upwards of
$5 a piece at the moment so they can
wait if you're not trying to spend too
much extra I also wish that Wizards
would print enemy cycles of Tango and
cycle lands as it' be nice to have a bit
of upside to sweeten the deal of cutting
temples the other change I made to the
Mana base was swamping out a swamp and a
forest for two more Islands since we
added several more cheap creatures in
blue I could delve a lot deeper into
building a three-color Mana base but I
won't be doing that in this video due to
the aforementioned acceptableness of
this deck's Mana basee all right those
are my improvements overall I like this
preon okay if I was to be charitable I'd
say that it was probably built with the
intent of allowing modification paths
for both a zanier full theft build and
for the path I chose of emphasizing
combat damage and evasive creatures if I
was to be uncharitable I'd say that
evasive creatures is the only build of
this deck that actually works with ganty
and that all of the UN synergistic goofy
theft stuff is at best an obstacle to
throw newer players off the path of
making the deck actually decent because
who's going to cut a chaos wand or a
villainous wealth when those cards are
so fun whatever the case may be this
precon reminds me a lot of older ones in
its lack of focus though its decent card
quality and solidly built Mana base will
certainly lead to it performing better
than most of
those thanks for watching and as always
a big thanks to my patrons who allow
making YouTube videos to be my full-time
job that's pretty cool you can also let
me know in the comments if you liked
this or if you agree with my analysis of
the deck I tried to go a bit more in
depth on the improvements as I kind of
Blaze through them with blame game